Poland has seen some of its largest protests in years,
with a reported half a million people marching against
the ruling law and Justice Party
on the 34th anniversary of the 1989 election
that effectively ended communist rule in the country.
Donald Tusk,
former Polish prime minister
and president of the European Council
and now leader of the Civic Platform,
spoke at the event,
saying today
I'm vowing to win,
to make those in power accountable,
to mend injustice
so that in the end
people can be reconciled.
Been increasing anger at the government
after a law was passed that allowed the ruling party
to investigate whether the opposition
had been unduly influenced by Russia.
President Duda has said that he will propose motions
to water down the Bill.
Criticism came not just from home,
but also from the US State Department
and the European Commission,
as it could ban people from holding political office
without proper oversight from the judiciary.